>> Tucker: AT CAREER DAY IN
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL IS A GREAT
CHANCE TO GET KIDS DREAMING
ABOUT THEIR FUTURES, WHEN THEY
CAN GROW UP AND BECOME TEACHERS,
DOCTORS, AND APPARENTLY, COP
HATERS.
ONE ELEMENTARY SCHOOL IN CHICAGO
ENRAGED PARENTS UNDERSTANDABLY
AFTER THE PRINCIPAL INVITED AN
ACTIVIST TO THE SCHOOL WHO
ROUTINELY POST A VIOLENT
ANTI-COP RHETORIC ONLINE.
MATT HAS ALL THE DETAILS.
>> MARY BETH COULD NOT SUDDENLY
RETIRED WITH JUST WEEKS LEFT IN
THE SCHOOL YEAR, AFTER SHE
INVITED A POLICE EXTREMIST TO
TALK TO STUDENTS AT WILDWOOD
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL HERE IN
CHICAGO.
THAT EXTREMIST ON SOCIAL MEDIA
CALLED HIMSELF A RADICAL.
HE POSTED ONLINE, F HIM AND HIS
FAMILY.
HE ALSO POSTED THE TERM CP DK
WHICH STANDS FOR A CHICAGO
POLICE DEPARTMENT KILLERS.
HE REFERS TO COPS AS PIGS AND
POSTED ABOUT KILLING ALL THE
RICH PEOPLE.
HE HAS HATRED FOR POLICE BECAUSE
HE ALLEGES THAT A CHICAGO POLICE
OFFICER KILLED HIS FRIEND WITH A
TASER.
SUPPOSEDLY SHE BROUGHT HIM INTO
TALK ABOUT HIS POETRY AND CIVIC
WORK BUT THINGS WENT OFF THE
RAILS.
>> HE TOLD THEM THAT ALL THE
POLICE WERE BAD AND ALL THE
POLICE WANTED TO KILL PEOPLE.
I WAS VERY DISAPPOINTED THAT
SOMEONE WOULD COME INTO THE
SCHOOL AND PREACH HATE.
TELL MIKE ABOUT THE POLICE.
OR EVEN IF HE WAS TALKING ABOUT
ANYONE ELSE, IT WOULD HAVE UPSET
ME.
>> SHE WROTE A LETTER EVERY
APOLOGY BEFORE RESIGNING WRITING
IN PART, I WAS PRESENT WHEN HIS
NARRATIVE TOOK A TURNABOUT
POLICING AND I IMMEDIATELY
INTERVENED.
I CARE ABOUT YOUR CHILDREN AND I
WOULD NEVER EXPOSE THEM TO THIS
TYPE OF ACTIVITY.
THE PRINCIPAL HAS RECENTLY BEEN
PRESSURED BY SOME PARENTS TO
INTRODUCE ANTIPOLICE
PHILOSOPHIES TO STUDENTS.
NEARLY EVERY PARENT WE TALKED TO
SAID THE PRINCIPAL WAS DOING AN
EXCELLENT JOB AND ENDED UP
MAKING THIS GRAVE MISTAKE.
WE TALKED TO ONE CHICAGO POLICE
OFFICER WHOSE CHILDREN WENT TO
THE SCHOOL AND HE SAID THAT
CAREER DAY SPEECH WAS AN
INDOCTRINATION AND NOW THE
CHILDREN HAVE BEEN EXPOSED TO
EAT THOSE ONLINE ACCOUNTS.
>> I'M INSULTED AND ANGRY.
I CAN'T BELIEVE SHE DIDN'T BET
HIM PROPERLY.
SOME OF THE THINGS ON HIS
FACEBOOK ACCOUNT ARE HORRIBLE.
>> ETHOS DECLINED OUR REQUEST
FOR AN INTERVIEW.
I BRIEFLY SPOKE TO MARY BETH
COULD NOT ON THE PHONE AND SHE
EMPHASIZES THAT SHE SUDDENLY